[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
19 avril après deux nouveaux suicides
les policiers appellent au rassemblement
devant le commissariat ce vendredi il
réclame des mesures fortes pour endiguer
la recrudescence de suicides depuis le
début de l'année 28 policiers ont mis
fin à leurs jours
ce drame a ému toute la france mais
aussi le monde entier la cathédrale
saint michel notre dame de paris a pris
feu lundi à 18h50 un symbole fort pour
la communauté catholique père benoît
d'argenlieu prêtre à la paroisse de
montigny guyancourt sera notre invité
est déplacement de députés et ministres
dans les yvelines mais aussi préparation
du week-end pascal
comme chaque vendredi un coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine
les policiers de nouveau dans la rue
après deux récents suicides
hier ils se sont rassemblés devant les
commissariats en milieu de journée
ils demandent à être reçus en urgence
par le gouvernement et réclame des
mesures fortes pour endiguer ce fléau
je le rappelle depuis janvier et 28
personnes se sont donné la mort écouter
leurs revendications devant le
commissariat de guyancourt où une
vingtaine de policiers étaient
rassemblés au micro de calypso vanier on
a beaucoup de gouvernements qui ont
essayé maintes et maintes fois voilà de
lancer des projets de mettre en place
des choses
les collègues trouvent que c'est passé
alors c'est peut-être pour ça que
d'ailleurs on en a qui partent
malheureusement qui décide de faire ce
soit fatale de partir ça fait trois
quatre ans que
voilà le la conjoncture sociale en
france c'est difficile on a toujours
l'empreinte des attentats qui est là
donc on nous demande beaucoup notamment
concernant vigipirate
donc je pense que c'est un peu lui le
portefeuille en fait c'est un peu
étoffés démission a toujours mal manque
de personnel des moyens qui sont
cruellement manquants et du coup je
pense que les collègues ont du mal à
répondre à la demande
lundi 15 avril 18h50 la cathédrale saint
michel notre dame de paris prend feu et
pour parler de ce drame avec de hauts
plateaux le père benoît d'argenlieu
prête à la paroisse de montigny du en
cours bonjour bonjour manon c'est un
drame qui a ému toute la france mais
aussi le monde entier un incendie a
ravagé la cathédrale saint michel notre
dame de paris au lendemain plusieurs
centaines de catholiques étaient réunis
place saint michel à paris afin de se
recueillir
certains lisent et des textes religieux
d'autres des extraits de l'oeuvre de
victor hugo
c'est un symbole de votre religion qui
est parti avec cet incendie oui je crois
que je suis comme comme la plupart des
français d'abord évidemment la plupart
des chrétiens mais la plupart des
français et plus largement même de dans
le monde
je suis vraiment bouleversé par ça c'est
vraiment un symbole effectivement vous
vous employez le bon mot un symbole qui
est qui est parti qui est parti en fumée
fin qui est et l'émotion que ça suscite
chez moi c'est je crois vraiment que
c'est de la tristesse aussi mais quel
gâchis quoi quel gâchis et et et pas
seulement je crois pour les croyants
vigano comme croyant je trouve ça je
suis particulièrement affectées et
bouleversé mais je crois que ça dépasse
largement la question des croyants et
c'est ça qui me c'est ça qui me touchent
aussi énormément et de voir cette
émotion je crois que je suis interpellé
par ça et de voir aussi beaucoup de non
croyants et hier je voyais un jeune qui
rentrait dans l'église qui une église du
11e siècle envoyé à guyancourt et qui me
dit je dis mais qu'est ce que fait de
volailles du beurre en fait on a des
trésors je suis jamais rentré ici et
quand j'ai vu que la cathédrale de paris
a brûlé je me suis dit je peux pas ne
pas au moins avoir découvert cette
église de ce trésor devant lequel je
passe tous les jours mais dans lequel je
suis jamais rentré c'est important
d'être unis dans ces moments là pour
votre communauté et je crois que c'est
très important
c'est très important je crois que c'est
une épreuve
et comme toute épreuve je crois que ça
rassemble oui
un d'eux il rassemble les familles qui
sont justes et libres et des obsèques
hier aussi voyez ça même des gens qui se
parlaient plus depuis des années ben ça
rassemble
voilà c'est alors très vite le mot
miracle est apparu pour évoquer le fait
que le feu n'est pas à temps les poutres
des tours qui supporte les cloches vous
aussi vous pensez à un miracle alors je
sais pas s'il faut parler de miracle en
tout cas je trouve ça assez étonnant
surtout en entendant le le témoignage de
l'aumônier des pompiers je sais pas si
vous l'avez entendu j'ai été assez
bouleversé par sa il disait le plus
important pour moi
vous savez que que la cathédrale notre
dame de paris il ya la chose la plus
importante qui a dans l'axé de
cathédrale vous savez pourquoi elle
était construite c'est c'est pas
simplement pour la sainte là les
reliques de la couronne mais c'est pour
simplement abriter quelque chose qui est
le pain l'eucharistie la présence de
dieu en fait c'est bon alors c'est juste
un morceau de pain pour ceux qui ne
croient pas pour nous c'est jésus vivant
ressuscité qui est là et cet homme se
est allé avec les pompiers rentrer dans
la cathédrale en feu et au moment où il
sort vous voyez du du tabernacle jésus
il raconte qu'à ce moment là il ya la
tour nord qui a qui casse et c qui enfin
le feu était maîtrisé à ce moment là et
lui il il y voit clairement quelque
chose d'une intervention tout cas les as
et interpellante donc voila et un élan
de solidarité mondiale s'est produit
pour la reconstruction de la cathédrale
notre dame et les dons ont dépassé les
15 millions d'euros mais cette ampleur
des dons commencent à provoquer une
polémique certains andro great que cette
somme ne soit pas donnée aux plus
démunis comment réagissez vous
alors c'est vrai que moi je suis très
touchée par parler par la générosité des
personnes mais je suis très touché par
cette générosité cette solidarité qui
ceux qui manifestaient et ça pose vous
avez tout à fait raison de le dire la
question aussi de l'ouverture aux
pauvres je pense qu'il faut pas trop
vite opposé voyez l'église et
l'ouverture aux pauvres parce que
l'église vous voyez c'est d'abord un
lieu pour les pauvres
voyez normalement voyez l'église elle
est le lieu pour les pauvres et de
toutes les pauvretés qu'ils soient
envoyés il ya des pauvreté matérielle
des pauvretés psychologique des pauvreté
spirituelle voyage à l'instant même là
je suis en gt avec cinq minutes de
retard parce que j'étais
j'arrive de mon église là est une dame
arrivée avec des fleurs vous voyez me
disant elle voulait remercier dans
l'église me disant à la fois une joie
qu'elle avait il ya 25 ans elle était
guéri d'une leucémie de manière
inexplicable
elle me dit ça là à l'instant et je dis
mais pourquoi est ce que vous venez et
elle me dit à la fois pour remercier et
puis pour confier une situation
difficile de sa fille oui il ya une
vraie pauvreté qui n'était pas
matérielle mais il ya une vraie pauvreté
là
2 que travers sa fille en ce moment cet
incendie s'est produit lors de la
semaine sainte qui je le rappelle est
pour les chrétiens la semaine précédant
pâques est destiné à commémorer la
passion du christ chaque jour de cette
semaine et surtout les trois derniers à
une coloration particulière que
représente le vendredi saint pour votre
communauté
alors pour nous le vendredi saint ce et
c'est la mort de jésus et jésus pas
seulement un homme mais on pourrait dire
la mort de dieu dieu meurt c'est très
étonnant
et si vous rentrez dans nos églises vous
verrez que les les statuts normalement
sont recouvertes que l'hôtel est vide et
n'eut que on ne s'habitue elle ment il
ya un lieu on pressée devant le saint
sacrement devant le tabernacle
hélas le tabanac les vides et oui on
fait cette expérience qui moi me saisit
toujours comme prêtre ne pas savoir où
prier de pas savoir où poser mon regard
les croix normalement sont recouvertes
elles sont même enlevé et et c'est
l'expérience d'un monde sans dieu en
fait c'est vraiment cette expérience l'a
convié vendredi
aujourd'hui et c'est très très très
perturbant pour moi et pour le week end
pascal quels sont les programmations à
venir dans votre paroisse de montigny
guyancourt alors eh bien pour nous le
week-end pascal veille c'est le le
samedi soir dès le samedi soir dès la
nuit de samedi à dimanche
et puis le dimanche à 11 heures au cap
saint jacques à la grande messe de
pâques
la grande messe où on célèbre la
victoire de l'homme de la mort de la vie
sur la mort plus tôt et puis et alors
en fait ça on célèbre sa 11 heures c'est
une grande messe et puis il ya aussi un
temps de fête après l'après midi pour
les enfants une chasse aux oeufs de
pâques pour fêter pour célébrer aussi
ensemble en famille cette joie de la
victoire de la vie sur toute mort merci
benoît d'argenlieu d'avoir été notre
invité je le rappelle vous êtes prête à
la paroisse de montigny en cours et
soyez vigilant le périmètre de sécurité
autour de la cathédrale saint michel
notre dame de paris établi par la
préfecture de police est toujours
d'actualité
les stations de métro sont fermées
également jusqu'à nouvel ordre
concernant la circulation des voitures
et des piétons elle est interdite sauf
exception jusqu'au 22 avril
suite on passe au reste de l'actualité
de la semaine
[Musique]
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
jean michel blanquer air était à
versailles hier pour annoncer la
création d'un campus d'excellence
il sera situé au coeur des écuries
royales patrimoine art ou encore
gastronomie l'objectif est de développer
ces métiers en lien avec le château aux
reportages doré lire 11 et nicolas
d'andry les écuries royales de
versailles vitrine du savoir faire à la
française
prochainement 6000 mètres carrés seront
entièrement dédiés aux filières
d'excellence les métiers de paysages
d'art ou encore du patrimoine bâti
seront notamment représentés du fait du
drame que nous avons vécu en début de
semaine ces métiers d'art sont
particulièrement à regarder parce que
nous devons former des jeunes à ces
métiers sur les métiers d'art les
métiers de la construction
tous les métiers qui vont être impliqués
dans la reconstruction de notre dame de
paris
pas de création d'établissements pour ce
projet l'idée est de réunir sur un même
lieu des institutions déjà existantes
pour donner la possibilité aux étudiants
de mieux se former dans un domaine c'est
pas un gadget
on vient là parce que dans son cursus on
doit faire un chef-d'oeuvre
on doit faire un projet et
on vient de semaine avec les enseignants
travailler sur un projet ou peut-être un
peu plus ou un peu moins
l'objectif est également de susciter des
vocations pour ces filières en recherche
de compétences la possibilité de
travailler en relation étroite avec les
filières professionnelles du secondaire
autour de tous les métiers du château ça
permet à mon établissement en fait
d'élargir le champ et le spectre de ses
activités ça me permet aussi d'être en
prise en prise directe sur des lycéens
qui vont pouvoir ensuite intégrer
éventuellement l'école nationale
supérieure des arts décoratifs
d'hébergement des infrastructures
culturelles et sportives compléteront le
dispositif pour l'heure aucune date n'a
été avancée pour l'ouverture de ce
campus pas de chiffres non plus
concernant le financement de ce projet
un échange entre plusieurs député des
yvelines et les types de la carte de
notre département s'est déroulée pour
faire le point sur les prestations
sociales et les problématiques
rencontrées par l'organisme reportage
d'aurélie rose mieux comprendre les
missions de la caisse d'allocations
familiales des yvelines afin de mieux
aider la population
voilà l'objectif de ces échanges entre
sept députés yvelinois issus de la
majorité et l'équipe dirigeante
c'est marquant en ce début d'année la
hausse du nombre de bénéficiaires de la
prime d'activité l'occasion de faire le
point sur sa mise en place dans notre
département nous avions anticipé
l'organisation avec à dispositif
d'accueil dédié en fait aux nouveaux
bénéficiaires de la prime d'activité
avec une organisation également de back
office dédiées pour absorber le pic de
charge
donc c'est vrai que globalement malgré
le chiffre donc l'augmentation
importante de bénéficiaires de cette
prime consécutive aux annonces
gouvernementales
on a été globalement en capacité
d'absorber le choc de la réforme au 31
décembre 2018 dans les yvelines ont
compté plus de 235 me la locataire parmi
les sujets abordés lors de cette matinée
le recouvrement des pensions
alimentaires ou encore l'accompagnement
des bénéficiaires
objectif aller encore plus loin en
matière d'accès au droit
on a vraiment besoin qui beaucoup plus
d'interconnexions pour ne pas dupliquer
les choses mais aussi pour que les uns
formation qui parviennent alain
parviennent également à tous les autres
pour qu' on n'est pas de encore une fois
de trous dans la raquette
une rencontre dans le cadre de la
stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
voulue par le gouvernement dès 2020 par
exemple le numéro pour joindre la caf ne
sera plus surtaxé
autre déplacement la ministre de la
justice nicole belloubet était ce
mercredi 17 avril à la maison centrale
de poissy
elle est venue constater l'effondrement
d'un mur extérieur de la prison survenu
le 28 mars dernier
l'occasion d'évoquer l'avenir de la
structure
nicole belloubet en visite à la maison
centrale de poissy la ministre de la
justice est venu constater
l'effondrement d'un mur extérieur de la
prison survenu le 28 mars dernier
mesurée évidemment les inquiétudes qui
peuvent être celle de la population
quand vous avez un mur d'une prison qui
s'écroule il y à de véritables
inquiétudes que je comprends bien et
surtout envisagé avec monsieur le maire
l'avenir l'avenir pour la ministre passe
par une rénovation du site la femme
politique propose de débloquer une
enveloppe d'environ 60 millions d'euros
moi il me semble vraiment nécessaire si
nous restons apprécié ou centre ville
comme je le souhaite que nous nous
engagions pour la ville et pour les
habitants de cette ville à rénover
complètement ces lieux et à en faire
vraiment une prison moderne secure avec
des objectifs clairs de détention de son
côté le maire de la commune karl olive
propose une alternative déplacer la
prison une consultation citoyenne
devrait être lancé auprès des habitants
de la commune
la question qui sera posée c'est
êtes-vous non favorables au maintien de
la maison centrale en centre-ville
je souhaite le faire d'ici le mois de
juin dans une forme juridique que nous
dans laquelle nous travaillons qui sera
évidemment autorisé la maison centrale
de poissy est installé en centre ville
depuis 1821 il compte aujourd'hui 193
détenus dont 35 à perpétuité
on passe tout de suite au reste de
l'actualité en ile-de-france avec nos
confrères devient grand paris
[Musique]
trois jours consacrés aux élus des
communes franciliennes le salon des
maires d'ile-de-france et des
collectivités locales 2019 a ouvert ses
portes mardi au pari event center de la
ville est un événement organisé dans un
contexte social particulier et dans un
moment de réflexion pour réformer les
collectivités territoriales et leurs
relations plus de précisions sur leurs
préoccupations avec ce reportage
un an avant les élections municipales
dernier coupé de ruban pour stéphane
beaudet le président de l'association
des maires d'île de france
avec la crise et gilet jaune et la
baisse des dotations de l'état
le salon des maires d'île de france
s'ouvre dans un contexte tendu le
message des élus franciliens est clair
ils veulent retrouver des moyens
d'action et un sentiment de
recentralisation de perte de moyens de
dilution dans des grandes agglomérations
et puis surtout il ya un sentiment de
défiance du pouvoir central vis-à-vis
des collectivités qui est devenu
insupportable et la force du mouvement
des gilets jaunes et des cahiers de
doléances qu'on a mis en oeuvre a
démontré qu'il y avait une défiance du
peuple français sur le pouvoir central
mais qui avait en même temps une demande
de renforcement du pouvoir local
on en a assez de la technostructure qui
doublonnent qui complexifie qui empêche
qui interdit voyez ça fait dix ans que
le grand paris a été lancé
combien de réalisations concrètes en
disant tellement peu et pourquoi parce
que on a multiplié les procédures parce
qu'on a multiplié les acteurs on a cinq
niveaux d'administration locale en ile
de france
aujourd'hui 80 % des français sont
favorables à une modification de
l'organisation des collectivités
beaucoup d'élus demande un acte iii de
la décentralisation
les français sont très attachés aussi à
l'équité et il y à des domaines qui en
fait sont des domaines pour lesquels
l'état joue un rôle d' équité et donc
c'est la grande discussion que nous
devons avoir pour comment dire
perfectionner ce qui reste à l'état et
ce qui va dans les collectivités
territoriales
le salon réunira encore cette année élus
franciliens et décideurs qui débattront
autour de grands thèmes d'actualité
vingt-deux mille visiteurs tenteront de
se frayer un chemin dans les allées du
salon
vous allez peut-être partir à la chasse
aux oeufs ce week-end de pâques comme le
veut la tradition dans les chocolateries
tout est prêt cette année la
confédération des chocolatiers
confiseurs de france lance même une
opération solidaire avec les enfants
hospitalisés et les personnes âgées
marylène iapichino dans la chocolaterie
du mesnil-saint-denis la penzé poussins
ont investi la vitrine depuis un mois et
pour les derniers préparatifs de pâques
les livraisons s'enchaînent
là forcément faut un peu se moquer parce
qu'à un moment on va être un peu
submergé donc on a intérêt à en mettre
un peu en avance dans l'est dans les
commerces
rien n'est laissé au hasard dans la
présentation quand on met pas de socle
regardez ce que ça donne
alors moi j'ai coupé des gobelets et
j'ai fait des peuples parce que pâques
c'est aussi l'occasion de laisser
s'exprimer sa créativité
mon chef s'appelle nicolas morin a
proposé un sujet qui s'appelle là où la
cloche
mais d'ici le chocolat se veut aussi
généreux membres de la confédération des
chocolatiers confiseurs de france
christophe bertrand a fait un constat
simple les chocolatiers pour être sûr de
ne pas manquer prévoit large quitte à
rester avec des stocks de chocolat sur
les bras une fois pas que passer il ya
deux solutions soit on défait les
sachets en remet chocolat au fond noir
et on va récupérer peut-être 20 kg de
marchandises soit à peu près de 200
euros de marchandise ou alors avec ses
20 kg de marchandises qui représentaient
200 sujets ont fait plaisir à 200
personnes cette année les six boutiques
de l'arenas reid participent à
l'opération généreuse pâques
au total ils sont 160 chocolatier à
s'investir dans toute la france donc
l'idée qu'on a déterminés c'est dire aux
gens si vous voulez offrir un sujet un
enfant qui est hospitalisé on va nous se
charger de l'offrir à ses hôpitaux et on
mettra en plus pour chaque sujet offert
un sujet que nous offrirons
et puis à la fin de toute façon on va
offrir également ce qui va nous rester
des partenariats sont aussi réalisées
avec des ehpad pour ne pas oublier les
personnes âgées la générosité du
chocolat trouve ici tout son sens avis
aux plus créatifs et habiles de leurs
mains
elena et camille vous propose de
fabriquer un trophée lapin de pâques
comptait quatre heures de réalisation
indications en images
camille et elena se sont rencontrés il
ya quelques mois sur le réseau social
instagram toutes les deux passionnés de
créations artisanales
elles ont pris l'habitude de travailler
ensemble pour attendre la chasse aux
oeufs un trophée lapin de pâques
première étape avec elena le lapin aux
poupons je vais faire l'arrière de la
tête de notre petit lapin donc c'est
très simple l'arrière de la tête les
unit je me contente de bien fixer la
matrice de façon à ce que les deux
moitiés soit bien que les mêmes contre
l'autre je bloque mon fils et je
commence à tourner pour couvrir avec de
la laine de couleur différentes
nouvelles ont su créer des éléments du
visage en prenant garde à bien respecter
la symétrie ont rajouté quelques tours
assez lâches pour faire les oreilles sur
la partie supérieure du complot
vient ensuite le découpage l'on découvre
enfin la phase de son pompon donc
maintenant on va sculpter le lapointe
pour les oreilles et les night il est
des aiguilles est feutrée qui vont venir
mélanger les fibres de la laine et lui
donner une autre texture les yeux même
chose vous pouvez vous servir de
l'aiguillât faudrait pour enfoncer les
poils des yeux et dans les sept
solitaires plus naturel quand ils vont
en prendre
de son côté camille ses talents en
couture et crochet s'occupe de la partie
textile elle commence par fabriquer un
noeud en découpant 3 rectangle de tissu
de tailles différentes
un pliage précis pour former des tubes
c'est ensuite les assembler pour
constituer notre nom en tissu et là on
va juste fermé par quelques points à la
main le petit tube à l'arrière d'une
partie la plus technique le cadran en
crochet pour cela qu'à mini va venir
couvrir un cerceau métallique avec trois
méthodes de crochets différentes
les maïs et riz doit être par multiple
de 6 elles serviront de base pour les
deux autres tours cette étape minutieuse
et la plume
reste ensuite le fond l'étape la plus
simple et la plus rapide
on va venir prendre une feutrine épaisse
quelque chose qui a un petit peu de un
petit peu de tenue sur lequel on va
venir coller en cercle de tissus qu'on
aura des coupés
ne reste plus qu'à coups en fond et
cadres en avant de procéder à
l'assemblage final votre trophée lapin
de pâques est fin prêt pour venir
décorer la chambre de votre enfant
si vous n'êtes pas aussi doué que nos
deux créatrices vous pouvez toujours les
contacts et sur leur compte instagram et
passer commande
nous passons à notre rubrique ça s'est
passé comme chaque vendredi nous vous
ouvrons les archives de tv 78 et en ce
week-end de pâques qui s'annonce retour
sur l'élection du pape françois c'était
en mars 2013
[Musique]
habemus papam nous avons un pape les
catholiques vont désormais célébrée
chaque jour françois à l'église saint
victor de guyancourt les fidèles étaient
déjà ému avant la messe ce jeudi midi
je viens pour le passé laisse madier
paul et l'élection des papes
françois pauly je suis très heureuse a
pour l'élection du nouveau pape parce
que ça donne une joie à l'église d'avoir
un parent dans notre continent mais qui
est pour tout le monde
quelque chose de nouveau vous êtes
content oui madame un moment fort
partagé avec le jeune père fabrice du et
qui vit son premier changement de
souverain pontife
c'est une nouvelle figure pour laquelle
on va prier au quotidien qui va pouvoir
aussi donner certaines directions à
l'église et chaque pop bain
arrivé avec ses idées avec des projets
pour l'église donc ça va changer un
certain nombre de choses même s'il faut
pas s'attendre à une révolution majeure
dans les quelques semaines ce nouveau
peuple par françois et ben imprimera
l'histoire de l'église à sa manière un
pape jésuite jesús c'est ce sont des
prêtres religieux qui ont fait le voeu
de pauvreté et qui vivent de manière
assez exigeante cette pauvreté
françois ça fait référence à saint
françois d'assise saint françois
d'assise et le ce1 par excellence qui
incarne la vertu de la pauvreté qui
incarne aussi l'amour de la nature
l'amour le dialogue interreligieux
françois entre saint françois avait été
discuté avec les musulmans à l'époque
pour que ce dialogue était plus que
complexe
donc ça dit déjà fortement quelque chose
de la manière dont il sera pas en chaque
messe le pape est nommé l'homme le pape
et l'évêque par leur très bon alors tout
l'enjeu c'est de pas se tromper pas
mettre notre pape benoît à ce moment là
jésus de plus
je sais
sa première fois s'est bien passée et
restera un souvenir extraordinaire tout
comme la découverte du pape
hier soir au moment où j'ai appris que
la fumée était blanc je recevais un
couple en préparation au mariage c'était
dans mon bureau au presbytère donc je
leur ai dit ce que je crois qu'ils ont
appelée à lui signer mais je leur ai dit
est ce qu'on peut tout arrêter parce
qu'il faut qu'on voie le nouveau pas pu
su aller chercher une bouteille de
champagne et donc avec ce couple on a
débouché la bouteille de champagne
accueilli le nouveau pape et une fois
seulement qu'on savait qu'il s'était
j'ai fermé mon ordinateur et on a pu
continuer la préparation au mariage
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo au
retour de l'information lundi à 18h dans
le 7-8 journal d'ici là passez un
excellent week-end pascal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour